hey what's up everybody welcome to the
ru garbage comedy podcast
yes gang hit that subscribe button to
make sure that you get the episodes
as they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
[Music]
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show where
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and find if they grew up classy or if
they're complete trash
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day here at gas
digital studios in the east village new
york city
my co-host coming at you right [ __ ]
next to me
he's my old pal he's the brains behind
the operation he put this whole [ __ ]
thing together
let me tell you something folks just a
quick reminder the next time you're
reaching for a best pal
you make it a kippy this guy tastes
great and he's less filling
give it the [ __ ] up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey what's up everybody thanks
so much for tuning in
um as always we appreciate all support
as we get this off the ground
uh we are currently in the top 200 on
itunes please make sure you rate review
subscribe
uh also full video available on youtube
you can you can subscribe there as well
we appreciate all the [ __ ] support
thank you yes sir and gang we could not
be more excited to have our very special
guest with us here today
through the magic of satellite
technology
coax cable got a man on location right
now 5g
this young man is a very funny stand-up
comedian he performs all over the
country
you know him from your mom's house with
tom segura and christina p
he's the [ __ ] pride of buffalo but
the big question in everybody's mind
today is he garbage
and i gotta say he was 15 minutes late
and he's sitting in front of venetian
blinds
so i'm going to go with the [ __ ] yes
ladies and gentlemen give it up for mr
josh potter everybody
i am so sorry for being i was going to
apologize up front about being late i'm
so sorry
oh don't be sorry i said 5 45 but
i i also was getting in a fight with my
landlord about it
that's what we want to hear i was going
to ask you why you were late that's good
with the [ __ ] super once i saw that
it was 2 30
i could have easily had been able to
have jumped on but my landlord and i
were
i have i put my cigarette butts
[Laughter]
thanks so much for being against me
i i diligently put them in empty cans
and then i
put the cans in there's an old barbecue
that's here
and i put the cans in there and then
when enough cans compile
i give you the hobo this is named red
feather that lives at the corner
uh you stick him with [ __ ] cigarette
butts in the cans when he's got to
deposit it
hey if he's got a little bit of work he
can't just do
couple minutes to take the butts out and
he's got all those cans but so i have
this system and then he's telling me
he's fine in cigarette but and i go
they are not mines how dare you
if you check the old barbecue inside the
red bull cans she'll be free i might add
ask rusty the hobo he'll back me up oh
that's [ __ ] great red feather is his
name and he's down
right at the corner and i'll bring them
down here to testify right now
holy [ __ ] i knew we were going to hit it
off i [ __ ] i love you already i'll
tell you that
i was wondering why you might be late i
was thinking like you were
that you were microwaving some nachos or
something like that
fighting with the landlord that is
[ __ ] perfect
josh potter we're happy to have him
where was it where was it left with the
landlord
uh i showed him i said this is my system
i'm like how dare you
pull out the charges i apologize i'll
deal with the others or something like
that
these others that he's great smokers or
whatever
now probably where are you coming at us
from i'm guessing it's not the hamptons
or uh or kenny bungport
oh no i live in uh east hollywood nice
all right okay that's hollywood
california right in the shadow of the
griffith observatory
oh an aristocrat aristocrat i like it
yeah it's nice it's not
very no it's not it's uh when i say the
shadow
it's behind the dumpster it's like times
square
for uh la basically
there you go that's where they filmed uh
rubble without a clue whatever the [ __ ]
it was called james dean
yeah not not but a couple miles away is
where uh the subway
exits out of speed you know when it's
not finished
yeah yeah you know where the subway
explodes out of the end
that's at hollywood that's at the
hollywood and highland station
where they ran out of money now
originally you're from buffalo
i am indeed yes which is a blue collar
town
adult yes 30 years i spent there
what was the uh what was the situation
growing up now did you have uh brothers
and sisters mom and dad
tell us sister my father's uh an
immigrant from
the middle east uh who's a well he's
greek but he grew up in the middle east
and then he came to buffalo
and my mom never lived anywhere else in
her entire life
okay buffalo forever so i love that i
love that
alex i love that i love that a trait in
a person wow
hunkers down and stays there for the
long haul dude not only that
up until two months ago lived in the
same
building wow holy
[ __ ] like born raised grew up
bought had a family in and then i
thought it was going to die
in but then decided to sell it at the
last second you know
housing troubles and what not economy
and all that
yeah like a little bit of cash i feel
that's like a is that a buffalo that's
that's i don't think i've ever been to
buffalo but the the picture i have in my
head is like it's one of those towns
like the blue collar
it's like lifetimers like they're in
there and they just stay forever it's
like hard to
break out of that cycle there was like
an exodus
at one point in the 90s i remember like
you know it was one of those places that
was booming during the rust belt times
yeah factories and all that [ __ ] and
then you know the late 80s early 90s
came and everything was like
tech you know so like when everything
was surging like when clinton was
president and everything was like
blowing up and everything was like the
economy's out of control in places like
buffalo
it was people were leaving in mass it
was tanking
charlotte and nevada and like all this
other stuff so then when 2008 happened
it was like everyone caught up to us
[Laughter]
you guys were ahead of the game you're
like yeah it was a home game for you
guys
so it's pretty easy on us we're like
this is just what we've been doing
welcome to buffalo everybody yeah right
and then when global warming comes in
and everything like that buffalo is
going to be like
a destination beachfront property yeah
yeah so did you grow up in a
single-family home did you grow up in an
apartment where we
were you in we had like a um so like
my gr my mother's grandparents or my
great-grandparents or whatever
built a home and they it was like a
duplex
it's like an upper upper and lower
situation
two family home okay and uh they always
kind of did the like
so the one family lived in it and then
one of the kids families and then they'd
switch and another kid's family and it
kind of just kept going
even my sister did that for a little
while she lived in there
and uh and then finally like came to the
point where my sister was like i'm
buying my own house
well i'm never living there ever
the family shunder after that yeah in my
parents divorce so like my mom was like
i can't afford
my dad is such a financial genius um
that he decided to refinance a home that
he like
completely owned
[Laughter]
uh right before the housing bubble burst
holy [ __ ] my mom was paying
rent on a family home or renter mortgage
whatever it is
on a family home uh you know here in 20
you know the last 10 years or whatever a
new a new lease
or a new mortgage a new mortgage on a
household that your family built and
once owned
yeah exactly dad [ __ ] her with that
then i was like you know what i'm out of
here
i think we should see other people yeah
that mortgage is in your name right i'll
see you later
what do i'm gonna go what did your dad
do for a living
uh he always worked in restaurants he
like would run them or
classic greeks yeah he's owned diners
and sold them and then
he owned a diner called hot dog heaven
for a couple years
[Music]
i'm listening that's right
and yeah coming to buffalo there
what's the typical buffalo what's a
typical buffalo dog what's the style
uh it's like that slimer i mean it's
like any other greek diner dude it's
like um
it's like here in new york basically but
i don't know they do they have in there
it's like the
the [ __ ] um like brown sauce with the
mustard and the [ __ ]
onions we don't do the brown sauce sauce
i don't know what that is
ketchup it looks like dog [ __ ] but it
tastes great
chili sauce yeah chili sauce maybe i
think kind of something like it's not
though it's something else i don't know
i mean it's like a mixture
it's weird it's they call them like
slime dogs we have like a couple texas
red hot places they call them it's like
all grieco there's like a guy named
louie
texas hearts and green slime dogs
that's a mafia [ __ ] dude that's [ __ ]
weird in buffalo
food [ __ ] it's a slime dog
oh yeah the greek restaurant crew and
buffalo's [ __ ]
that's the thickest thieves i presume
like the sopranos yeah yeah
so when you grew up in this house who
lived who lived in the one above you
in the in the like my grandparents that
my mother's parents did
okay and it was you and your sister you
said yeah
and your parents split up when uh they
waited until i was an adult
all right so i was already moved out
basically very nice and would you go on
vacation with your grandparents and all
that stuff the family was really tight
we did for a little while like uh you
know up until there was like a point
i don't know there was like a point
where like everyone like my
my grandparents have four children
including my mother
and everyone would go camping on
vacations and [ __ ] and then there was
like one moment where there was like a
fight
amongst people horse of course
no more of that like it was like we were
on an island or
maybe my mom did something must have
been my family because we ended up being
the guys are the odd man out that's
so drastic though that's such a garbage
fam
same thing with my family there's like
aunts and uncles we don't speak to and
it's like any time
the anytime the lines get blurred
between like family and like boss and
employee or landlord or neighbor like
when the family's that close together
and there's like that garbage dna in it
it's gonna fall apart at some point it's
so funny well it's and it's also like
because i
i still get along with pretty much i
mean if anyone talks to me i'll talk to
them
sure but they hold such like petty
grudges
like my mom will be like you're auntie
so and you're like who gives you who
even gives a [ __ ] i know dude we talk
about
[ __ ] we go home and they're like well
you know
john was late for dinner last tuesday
i'm like we're [ __ ] taking enemy fire
up here in new york
gives a [ __ ] about dinner you're costing
me five bucks and a birthday card
make amends with her will you jesus
christ it's
it's wild some of the like and then they
said
eight o'clock and they said and they
came in you know what i it's [ __ ]
like
wild you never talk to them again i know
it's like [ __ ] this is the this is
your
dude sister crazy it's insane
like well you know how she is she's been
doing it her whole life you're like
who gives a [ __ ] let's go so loud [ __ ]
grudges i know all right well that
paint's a pretty good picture we're
gonna get into a series of questions
here
uh josh we're going to ask you a series
of questions to determine whether you're
garbage or not
i want you to do us a favor i want you
to answer them open answer them honestly
all right and we'll see uh we'll see
where we go
number one we've been asking a lot of
people uh i'd like to know
what was the name of the street that you
grew up on
i grew up on a street called south union
road oh
that is not that it was a it was a
four-lane highway
dude there was no lie a toll booth it
wasn't on my street
but there was a toll booth not but like
three blocks three city blocks away like
you could
hear the trade trucks shift down
for the toll booth because the highway
was that close and there was a toll
booth right there
the best [ __ ] answer we've got if you
walk down
if you walk down my street and go to the
over ramp right before the center
if you got an over ramp by your front
door that's a bad look
ramp is where you can see the toll booth
oh
i was always wondering with the toll
booths where they parked these guys
oh they park in josh's driveway holy
[ __ ]
oh my god south union road south
south union over there on south union
that sounds more like
that sounds like where the dump is the
there's a cemetery that my cousin's
buried in
buddy quit bragging will you holy [ __ ]
yeah my grandparents oh i love it oh
that's jesus
um all right what was this is another
standard uh that a lot of people have
opinions about what was the name of the
grocery store your family went to
growing up
uh well it changed a few times but it
was bells
was when it was when i was a kid like
the first
incarnation of it that i can recall that
sounds pretty classy that sounds nice
can you paint us a picture of what uh
what belt was eventually uh
it just looked like an airplane hanger
[ __ ] it was like your first like
big story you know and eventually it got
bought out by uh
quality markets and then it was tops
friendly markets
and i think now it's stopped still maybe
but i'm not sure
now it's a toll booth yeah that's all
like northeast
like piggly wiggly type [ __ ] yeah right
that's a real garbage man yeah so it's
like that it's like your
uh standard what's that other one in the
carolinas the lion
the lion yeah oh yeah yeah yeah food
when i was a kid we were all petrified
of the food line because [ __ ] in 2020
it was like one of the first big expose
where they were like re-wrapping
meat changing the expiration date they
had
they had like john quinones undercover
in a [ __ ] food line
blowing up their spot it was [ __ ]
gross but i'll
tell you what if we will see we went to
the other side of williamsville and we
went to
wegmans wegmans
yeah is top of the line when the check's
cleared that's what i like to hear
you got to go to the good side of the
tracks gotta go hit the easy pass to get
the wegmans north union road that's
where the wagon is there is
there is a north union road
that'd be trashy if there was only a
south union road
north union road's actually kind of
horseshit also
holy north union what was uh what was
your fast food growing up what would uh
what was the big hit
in the potter family what's hilarious is
both my parents worked in
restaurants so you would think we
wouldn't eat in fast food because they
cooked and [ __ ] but they were like i
just cooked for
a million strangers all day oh you got
the shorter we're not stick
cooking for you we're a hundred percent
getting fast food so we got like um
just straight up mcdonald's i mean like
i can't even like put
any sort of bow and i wish i had some
sort of like
nostalgia for you but it was straight up
just chicken mcnuggets
yeah how many days a week were you
looking at
you know we'd get take out all the time
it was a lot of pizza hut too
we had a pizza hut down uh down our way
got a lot of pizza but you know in
buffalo i don't know if this counts as
fast food but pizza and wings
it wasn't just pizza hut we get pizza
hut once more but most of the time we'd
get like
regular pizza just like
with wings and [ __ ] you know but at a
pizzeria
right right right but my mom and dad
were like sometimes they were lazy and
they'd go to
the pizza hut but you know we'd go to
johnny's or whatever pizza yeah
nino's pizzeria or something yeah and
get wings and [ __ ] so that was a lot of
stuff while you're a kid you get a lot
of [ __ ] pizza and wings and bubbles
yeah
hmm now you guys claim is the buffalo
don't you guys claim buff the buffalo
wing oh yeah that's right yeah that's uh
yeah i mean it's like we just call them
wings but yeah they uh
[Laughter]
you know we got i mean it was invented
there
whatever the [ __ ] so i guess yeah we
claim it but um
i know in new york it doesn't seem like
you're like well i mean wings are
everywhere
but like here in california you'd be
surprised how
wildly you're like can't they just make
a chicken wing it's
i know dude it's so weird how food
doesn't travel like that
it's
[Laughter]
we got satellite links up in space i
know dude we're from philly and we live
in new york now it's 90 miles
it's like [ __ ] an hour and an hour
and a half and like there's like
the cheesesteak does it can't make it
past the bridge it's great yeah
it's crazy if 5g can make me gay why
can't we have a chicken
in california why can't i get a decent
homemade blue cheese over here i don't
get it dude
oh that's great um all right let's see
while we're on food a little bit have
you ever microwaved bacon
yeah i mean 100 paper towel
[Laughter]
do you still do it or like only in a
pinch or will you get the pan out and
and fry it i don't like the guri's i
mean i don't even [ __ ] with bacon
because i don't
um the process of making it and the
getting rid of the grease
is too much i'm just like too much
[ __ ] for that i'm just
don't even do it this guy runs a tight
ship i'll give you that
i mean there's like there's not a lot of
cooking
uh collateral damage that stars over
here when it comes
you know what i discovered recently was
they have rice that you can make
in the pouch put it in it comes in a
little pouch and it's already portioned
out and you just put the pouch
in the thing boil it you take it out
cut the pouch open boom no rice in the
pot
at [ __ ] i'm sorry did you say
recently discovered just found it
recently i don't know maybe it's been
around forever
i'm not saying i'm not trying to be
columbus over here don't tear down my
statue
i'm not saying i've discovered it but in
my world
oh i don't think i've ever had it oh
totally i know exactly what you're
talking about
it's in a bag like uh that has like
almost like
perforated holes in it a little bit yeah
and you just pop that bag in the water
and then you can pop it back
out ten minutes [ __ ] really good
whoever made that i want to blow them
they're [ __ ] geniuses that's car if
you're if you're
if you're changing your method and food
on
the dishes that's pretty [ __ ] trash
how often would you say as an adult now
or growing up did you have breakfast for
dinner
um i see like again my parents
were never i mean like we had a i have a
weird thing with food just because my
parents were never like
they'd always give me money to like eat
at school like have and get whatever
they have at school
that was the best when we have dinner it
was like they'd even leave money for me
to like get dinner
on the way home like at like a bar
like bar and grill type place or
something on the way home really you're
stopping into a bar getting take getting
taken yeah like getting [ __ ] wings or
a sub or some [ __ ] like that
so that's great that's trash
that's awesome though dude [ __ ] 14
years old heading home grabbing a
[ __ ] hogan 100
dude almost like weekly i'd get up i
used to get a sub from this place called
mike subs and i would get like
sounds great i'd get like hot peppers
yeah right mic subs
and i get hot peppers and i get like
hot sauce and something else like real
spicy on it or whatever
and i remember i get it so often that it
actually
gave me an ulcer for like a small ulcer
in my stomach and my doctor was like
what are you eating
you're 11. how the [ __ ] do you have
ulcers how old were you
i was [ __ ] like 13 or something like
that my doctor was like
how do you have it on ulcer and i was
like he's swinging pepto and [ __ ] like
an old detective he's asking me like
what am i eating and i told him i go to
mike's subs every day and i get this
thing and he's like
stop doing that i'm surprised
and take it away from your fairies yeah
and ulcer at 13.
just a really tiny one like to the point
where like you could like close back up
or whatever you know one of those ones
better but you know it was i was [ __ ]
up my
i just was [ __ ] up my stomach lining
by eating too much like spicy [ __ ] like
that's how do you think i've ever heard
of a kid going for [ __ ] hot peppers
on their sub i [ __ ] like i was like
burn my goddamn face off
that's awesome when did you start
growing facial hair yeah you look like a
guy that might have had facial hair
early thick you got yeah easy i started
losing my hair in high school too and
going like i remember my
uh mom mentioning i was going gray she
noticed i was going gray when i was like
14 or something like that she's like you
have grey hair this kid's little
little [ __ ] let a life of a 50 year
old by the time he was 15.
you're living on casual dining bar food
your whole life
it's pretty much it yeah that's what
happens when you have moth sticks all
the time
that'll [ __ ] age you dude that'll
shave a couple of years off the end let
me tell you something though the
shittier the bar
the [ __ ] better than mozzarella
sticks and i ain't got no problem with
that
hell yeah dude i mean [ __ ] we have i
mean i can't believe
they say like pizza logs aren't anywhere
else other than buffalo have you guys
have pizza logs i don't know what that
is a
pizza log yeah people no there's no
[ __ ] pizza logs anywhere how is the
pizza log
educate me baby what the [ __ ] is it it's
basically uh
like a cylinder like a little roll i
mean i'm sure you've seen like a pizza
roll
sure yeah one of those like pizza
pouches or whatever
yeah it's like that in a log form it's
like a cheese stick
but it's like a whole pizza and a stick
it's a log
we got to get somebody at the buffalo
from production to [ __ ] buffalo
oh yeah dylan get on it i don't know how
we have so many culinary things that
can't
break outside it's like wakanda you want
to keep it for yourself i get it we
yeah we are the champagne of bar food
i do it is like there's nothing i grew
up like hanging out in bars like my
family or whatever
and like you can tell dude sometimes
there's no better chicken finger than
like a chicken finger from a deep fryer
where the oil hasn't been changed in
like six years yeah
love it yeah dude you gotta check you a
chicken finger man
josh i mean uh yeah i like some chicken
fingers
subs that's another thing chicken
fingers subs it's like a
foreign idea to people oh we just
[ __ ] trash
we do those they're great i always
assumed that if i got chicken fingers in
a sandwich
they must have ran out of the other
chicken so they're just chicken fingers
is like a buffalo delicacy
and it's what we we like pride ourselves
on and you go outside of it you're like
how do they not have a chicken finger
sub on this menu a stinger
a stinger that's where you take
chicken finger sub and uh like the
the meat from like a uh philly cheese
steak and you put it on together
both of them together that's garbage
buffalo doc i got an ulcer too many
stingers
[Laughter]
yeah i mean that'll do it too holy [ __ ]
dude
what was uh what was your first car
growing up there in buffalo
i had a not a dodge neon a
chrysler neon what i don't know
why i don't even know why it was like a
weird
it's had i don't know why it was a
chrysler i remember them they looked
exactly the same right
yeah they were the same car i don't
understand what happened there but
it had a ski rack on it i remember that
keeping it classy hell yeah dude neon
were you a skier i did ski but i never
used the ski rack i just
threw the skis in my back seat i was
like i'm not putting him on the [ __ ]
rack yeah
dude anybody i always thought that guy
was a jerk off with the skis on the rack
any rack any rack is bad i just it came
with the car so i kept it but
sure sure sure i'm not putting [ __ ] on
it dude i remember people like we would
go skiing with like a friend and they
would like everything on the ski rack
or if you had one of those bubbles on
top all right that was a jerk off
those bubbles yeah yeah the bubbles it's
like if you have a kid maybe
also put the kid in the bubble and what
i'm saying like
if you're gonna have it use it i mean
that's yeah
that [ __ ] always [ __ ] annoyed me did
you do anything to the car when you when
you had it in high school did you hook
up with the stereo okay
i tried to i got i did not get like cool
speakers but i definitely got like a
sick ass
faceplate for the stereo yeah the head
unit
hell yeah
yeah where it's like you have to put it
in a little box and take it with you
yeah
yeah that one steals it for sure hell
yeah i mean
so and then i would label you know
because
we're burning cds back then now of
course of course and you can label the
files so that it shows up on your
head thing is different of course
that takes right different [ __ ] in there
he didn't have the cd changer in the
trunk did you by any chance
i did not have that to not on my first
car no but i did eventually have a car
that had that you got to save up for
that dude i remember the first time
i didn't know what that was i was in a
buddy's car and we like pulled over on
the turnpike to change cds i'm like what
the [ __ ] are we doing
yeah but imagine you were like holy [ __ ]
we can listen to like 40 songs
16 holy [ __ ] that's like
we have six cds that's like oh you're
like oh my god man
we're gonna listen to like 80 songs we
don't have to change anything
dude and now we have like we have
infinity stones oh yeah exactly
yeah it's [ __ ] nuts um all right when
was the last time you had mountain dew
uh what's i mean i guess what kind of
mountain dew
that answers the questions
you know i i feel like my here's the
thing i've had
i drink a lot of red bull i drink red
bull
obscene amounts every day okay and so
i have not had a mountain dew in a in a
while but i have had like the mountain
dew
kickstart thing uh like their energy
drink
yes okay that's functional it's a little
different
yeah i had that i no it just is a little
mountain dewy version i the red bull is
really my
everything it's really my i love the way
the can
feels in my hand i love the way it
smells man they got i like
this guy's trash holy [ __ ] i did morning
radio for
a very long time and i would drink four
of them
every morning like one of those four
packs i'd come in with one of those and
i'd pound them everywhere you guys
[ __ ] redline it would you ever
eat with an energy drink have a meal
i did it yesterday i had breakfast today
sir
it's no longer it's i'm like the guy who
like i don't even know what it is dude
it's like
i'll drink this at two in the morning
like if it's like two in the morning and
i'm like having like
fast food i'll have one of these i'll
say this
it is a i i was on them pretty heavy for
a while too
i usually had a little vodka and some
percocets in it but i was on him pretty
hard too
but i'll tell you what when you're real
thirsty i don't know what it is a
[ __ ] red bull tastes delicious you
know you're gonna taste it
with a wave of caffeine you know right
after but it does go down
pretty smooth oh the taste of it is like
nothing else like
i've never craved the taste of anything
else
anything that's [ __ ] trash dude wait
are you are you
are you a bite and sip guy or do you
do you'd like to drink separate the two
yeah well
what do you mean like if you take a bite
of food will you then take a swig of a
drink
yeah i'm usually like a chug eat a lot
and then
finish you know like because a bite and
sip guy with a red bull that's [ __ ]
no i don't do that i don't do any bite
and sip i usually like
drink drink drink drink
but i definitely like and then a lot of
times with these
i'll do i'll buy two one to pound
and then one to enjoy ah that's a [ __ ] i
do that with ipas a lot because i gotta
get some people
buy the bigger cans you know the bigger
those are real trashy the bigger cans
don't taste as good because there's
too much liquid inside of them these are
cold or long
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure this kid's
a loose cannon i'll tell you that he's
got him
i got to give it to him he's got his
weird garbage rules but it doesn't make
sense he backs them up
he backs them up with like solid logic i
believe
he lives he lives by a code i always
said i'm sophisticated garbage
and it's like the big thing we're
finding out after the show is like
as long as you can if you have a
reasoning behind it
i'm like hey you've put thought into it
and this is where you landed i'm [ __ ]
with it man
for sure have you ever gotten any red
bull uh
like swag like a red bull jacket or
anything like that oh my god the red
bull people when i worked in radio loved
me
and they would bring me they used to
bring me the new flavors every time
oh god bring me a little box for the new
flavors
oh boy did you ever have one of those
red bull fridges
i never not personally but i didn't get
them
i did get one in my office for a little
while oh that's clean
uh that is pretty classy and
every comedy club that has one i'm just
like i feel at home here this is
every comedy club has one in the green
room like under the desk or something
yeah that's when they're good they're
[ __ ]
ice cold that's when you know when
they're gonna be you're like oh they got
the red bull
that's more set that's how trashy most
comics are like
if there's a stock two by two red bull
fridge
in a green room i feel like a million
bucks i feel like i'm like this is
i feel am i performing at the taj mahal
right dude i feel like they rolled out
the red carpet i'm like if my mom could
see me now you know what i mean yeah
that's all i need
that in cold bottles of fiji water you
get a [ __ ] fridge with fiji water in
it
yeah i'm stealing them i think it's the
shape of the fiji bottle that gets me
going you feel classy or drinking from a
square box
polynesian yeah yeah and it's that clear
it's just
it's also very clear whereas when they
have the squiggles in them
see through it is good yeah this guy
[ __ ] get josh you [ __ ] get it josh
does get it man he
really really [ __ ] i always take one
for the road too when i'm leaving the
comedy club
always take one for the role i take a
red bull for the next day
he's got a school bag he's loading up
yeah
let me uh let's take it back to
childhood i'm curious did you go what uh
what religion or faith did you guys grow
up
uh just pretty much nothing i mean my
parents didn't really
try did you do christmas oh yeah yeah we
did all that stuff my fault
it was it was my mom was catholic and my
dad was greek orthodox and my mom
converted
to greek orthodox yeah because like they
had to for
to get married you know just like he's
my grandmother and [ __ ]
my parents never gave a [ __ ] about
religion so they never like pressed it
upon us you know what i mean but yeah
okay
the greeks keep it tight dude they they
keep a tight-knit circle the greeks they
do they don't [ __ ] around i live in this
yeah so
it's always like we do [ __ ] once in a
while and then my grandma died and we
were like never
yeah just keeping up appearances for her
yeah so it was christmas
was christmas big at your house it was
pretty big one
at first you know and then like we got
older and it got kind of like i said
my family started hating each other
but it was big in the beginning it was
like it was so big
and i i don't know it's like this is
kind of weird but like
i used to get so sad i'd be so happy
that i was
sad you know what i mean it was very
like because it was overwhelming how
awesome christmas was that i knew it
would
end and i would have to wait till next
year for it so i would be like depressed
all day
this kid had a rough [ __ ] childhood
isn't it
so that's a severe depression it was
like but that's how like
it was like in the beginning it was very
like uh a christmas story you know what
i mean like very short
uh picturesque [ __ ]
whatever that painting guy was that
norman rockwell
yeah yeah yeah all right so greek
immigrant father i'm guessing buffalo
that you probably you went with colored
lights on the tree and outside i would
assume
uh we won my mom did most of that my dad
could give two shits about that [ __ ] my
dad was more like if we're talking like
trash for him
he embraced america in
trash ways that was like like he got
tattooed like he went through a midlife
crisis that was like
sports cars tattoos like he bought uh
he got awarded he he was running old
country buffet i don't know if you
remember
that restaurant do i do i uh yeah so
marry me in the uh in the great buffet
wars
of 97 my father got a golden corral
closed
that was like down the street because of
uh
you know competition or whatever and old
country buffet
gave him a a mustang gt oh wait what
he's a reward
yeah this guy's a top earner holy [ __ ]
yeah he was the guy he was the third top
earner on the east coast they sent him
to hawaii and [ __ ] like
wait he was interested i'm sorry was he
a server like a general manager
no he he ran the restaurant i was gonna
say that's a hell of a [ __ ] busboy
yeah then they upped them up to uh
regional manager or whatever at the time
okay that's a [ __ ] serious job a
great job working for those corporate
restaurants man you're making a little
cash yeah he was for a little while and
then uh he would get
he would start feeling himself and then
he'd be like i'm buying a restaurant
and then that would go like i love that
garbage level of
mentality of like i get a little bit i
gotta [ __ ] push it to the limit i
gotta [ __ ] a mustang i can do anything i
want what are you talking about
he went back and forth a couple of times
he bought so he went from the old
country buffet thing top of the world
bought a restaurant drove him itself
into the ground
sold the restaurant started working
again for the old country buffet
corporation guys i'm sorry about what
happened i'm back i didn't even tell you
it's all no this is
not the old country i'm sorry the olive
garden corporation he went to alabama
darden
whatever that is so like red lobster
olive garden sure
all that [ __ ] and then he was like
feeling himself again
and he bought a bar in new kensington
pennsylvania a bar inside of a la quinta
inn
oh and was like this is gonna be my bar
i'm gonna run
and then he partied himself into the
ground and he flew too close to the sun
and that was the end of the road
and then he now he's a line cook at a
diner he used to own
but he collects social security and gets
paid under the table that's
by the guy that used it so that's pretty
good right yeah that's not bad
doing what he loves i tell you that the
bar one of our questions is have you
ever eaten at
a restaurant or a bar that was attached
to a motel
and i got to tell you owning a bar
inside the la cuenta that's [ __ ]
that's something else he must have seen
some real that's worse than eating at
the bottom
dude i would rather just mean the
regular i told my dad like what's the
game plan here i mean it's not like you
get
new people coming in yeah there's
nothing
we're in a la quinta inside new
kensington pennsylvania oh my god who's
coming here
yeah the regulars man the local town
folk that must be [ __ ] brutal yeah
there wasn't even a lot of them
dude i did a giggle like it was like a
ramada or something in the middle of
pennsylvania same thing
it was like in like the [ __ ]
cafeteria was the showroom
but there was a bar connected to it and
i was sitting down before the show
having a beer just
like waiting for the show to start and
the all the locals were there and they
were all amazon employees
and they would just get their paycheck
live at the motel
and then just drink at the bar all night
and i was like this is the
saddest [ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
[ __ ] it was rough
man oh my god that's my always like i
don't know if i attract this on the road
or something but
i'll always end up just like at a
buffalo wild wings or something
and it's like the daytime and i'm like i
don't even know where i am
like a buffalo wild wings on a highway
and you're oh i'm just sitting there and
i think like i'm gonna have a beer i'm
gonna eat some [ __ ]
and every [ __ ] time a guy sits down
next to me oh my god
where are you in from and i'm like i
don't want to do this dude
you know that guy does that every week
wherever he goes everywhere
that's the guy you feel bad for what the
[ __ ] his life like
yeah you're looking you're looking for
conversation and companionship
and a buffalo wild wings on a f at the
swing shift on a [ __ ] wednesday
yes they're still setting the bar up
yeah he hasn't figured out like
what's going on yet no you know the rest
of us know what's going on i think
there's romance to
to me honestly there's romance to
sitting in one of those bars
and like obviously we have a different
perspective the guy that's just sitting
there and has no outside perspective
just sitting there
with like a [ __ ] rolling rock or a
michelob or something
just letting it go riding off into the
sunset
i love it rolling rock well no that's
part of the
it is part of the fair but his ignorance
is like i don't feel bad for him i like
you
said i romanticize it as well and i like
just sitting there and watching a
uh highlight uh thing on the tv for
sports or whatever oh yeah
and then having that guy that guy's part
of it of course but it is annoying
but to be that guy would not be ideal
you know he goes back to his hotel room
after that
and he just starts crying and he's like
i don't even know why i'm crying i
just don't even know like he's just like
he just wants to feel something
why did i say that to josh god he was
such a cool guy
he was a cool guy i just talked to that
guy at the bar and i don't even know
what i'm talking about
that's a situation that if the guy asked
me what i did i would never tell them
i'm a comic because that would just
open up more no you go
vague consulting yeah i always say sales
and then they go what are you selling
that always puts me in a pickle
yeah i go medical
understand they don't supplies make [ __ ]
up they don't know anything yeah you've
made up a nice little career for
yourself josh
i like that yeah that's just medical
supplies yeah
tubing that's a medical tubing and then
they ask me something like oh i do the
tech stuff i don't know
you should talk to randy he's the guy
you really want to talk to
holy [ __ ] go ahead um
all right let's see since we're kind of
in there have you ever stolen a beer
glass from a bar
[Laughter]
that's such a garbage move but i love it
i used to get elaborate with it
i mean you ever take the salt and pepper
shakers
there was a a girl that my friend dated
that she used to take
forks and everything she used to take
everything it was like a couple
exhausting sometimes how many people use
that for yeah
yeah dude i was like why it's not even
like a special fork you know like i
would only take a bar glass really if it
was like
sure kind of cool a marquee bar yeah
yeah sure kind it had to have a little
bit of flair to it dude
i was out with my wife the one time
before it was before we were even gay we
were like dating
and i'm like oh this is a cool glass i
want to get like something like this for
the house
and then we walk out and she's got she's
like she's got it in her purse i'm like
you are a [ __ ]
keeper yeah the girls with the purses
i'm sorry
to interrupt you the girls with the
purses always were the reasons that i
[ __ ]
stole glasses that was always the thing
that would end up happening it would
just be like
yeah like oh oh that's great in your
purse i always thought
the pint glass the you'd want a pint
clash from a bar
if it did have like a cool logo if it
was like a certain beer but i don't know
what it is it's like just a
psychological thing
but drinking out of a plain pint glass
that has no
no lettering on it at all uh the beer
always tasted weird and
like shitty to me i don't know what you
mean like when there's no
it doesn't say like cores or anything on
the glass when it's just a plain pint
glass
yeah we haven't even talked about beer
but i
i won't drink now this is maybe like a
little snobby of me i won't drink draft
beer but i only drink shitty beer
so it has to be out of a bottle though
that's only what sure
you can't drink shitty beer draft no no
you sit down at a bar
what do you order are you gonna have a
beer okay like if
what part of the country are we in if
it's not if it's buffalo if i'm in
buffalo i'll get a molson canadian
that's not bad an international man of
mystery there you go well that's what
you think but in buffalo that's like a
bud
sure yeah you know what i mean yeah but
if i'm
in la or like somewhere else around the
country it's usually miller lite
that i'll order that's light's not bad
that's my trash dude it's [ __ ] it's i
drank it for years i'm not [ __ ] on
it but that's a trash beer
if your beer sponsors a football team if
you're the official beer of a football
team yeah you're trash
and i feel like miller lite you're
drinking that in like waist-deep water
in like a river somewhere surrounded by
a bunch of pontoon boats
it can go from that you could be in a
[ __ ]
tube going down a lazy river or you
could be
uh you could be at a dirt track you
could be
at uh
it's literally the beer for every
setting it is for every garbage occasion
yeah i've been on a private jet where
they've had i've opened the vertical
miller light what do they know i was
coming
that's great that's pure trash when
you're flying when you're flying private
still drinking miller
that's that's the truth and you can pick
anything and i
and i picked another light i drank
miller light in some hotels that would
blow your mind
where it's like almost disappointing
that
the people there go like are you serious
but the beverly hills hotel yeah he's
staying in hotels where the
where you where the [ __ ] where the
alarms are he's not bolted down
yeah international a warm miller like
pony please
um man that's good that's trash um
has anyone in your family ever collected
state quarters
that's so fun what a [ __ ] hilarious
question
my mom collected everything like that
she fell for all that [ __ ] the quarters
of course
beanie babies uh you know ninja turtles
uh your mom was collecting ninja turtles
i mean she was like she knew i liked
them obviously same with the beanie baby
she knew
us kids liked them but like it became
her then
yeah it was the collection aspect of it
yeah like of course i was going to
accept all of them but she was like sure
i got here's a shredder here's a [ __ ]
right here would you be allowed to play
with them or would they be they be put
away
uh well i could play with the ninja
turtles but the
ones that we started hoarding where i
could not play with them was the star
wars when the star wars characters came
out and they re-released the trilogy
and the star wars people they had to
stay in the box holy [ __ ]
dude i'm doing that now did you see any
of that cash you get to wet your beak on
that a little bit
all that shit's still in her and she's
like why do we have all this toys
here and i'm like that's you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you took my bubba fett you deal with it
yeah yeah you [ __ ]
sell that [ __ ] on ebay i don't think
that's so funny you figure it out
dude the state of course you're playing
my [ __ ] stepmom
had the map like the big foldable map
that you put
in and she had the date when the new
ones were coming out and she thought
that
she literally said to me one time she's
like this is gonna pay for your college
i'm like
that's gonna be worth [ __ ] nine
dollars i'm not gonna pay for dinner
what are you talking about
yeah i remember being like in parking
lots going through change and being like
i have a nebraska mom and be like yes
and like you'll be like
in the car like we had a astro hand too
that's holy that is that that's a
question that we asked we
didn't even have to ask he volunteered
the instruments
i just remembered that was i just
remembered sitting in it so i just
through that remember i got i got a
follow-up question
was it white with red interior by any
chance
uh no it was the uh gray it was like the
gray and
ash version on the outside and then in
the inside it had the same the gray
interior
yeah that's tough man they only made
those like three con they
made three colors it was that in tandem
yeah 88
88 won and it lasted for [ __ ] ever
every one of those [ __ ] vans smelled
like rotten eggs when you turned it on
yeah
the catalytic converter i think that's
what it was
so if your mom was a big collector
anybody in your family ever mess with a
metal detector no i thought and i
thought you were about to just blow my
mind again by saying
i'm like a little high so i thought you
were about to say what
my mom ultimately like her first
collecting thing was it wasn't a metal
detector or anything like that but my
mom collected precious moments do you
remember those [ __ ] things
what's that precious moments
they were ceramic like clowns and
animals oh dude they sold them on tv
yes they would be like and they would be
in like a little they
your mom would keep them in like a curio
cabinet or whatever
you want to hear this this is real
trashy i know exactly what you're
talking about and
number one those [ __ ] clowns used to
scare the [ __ ] out of
it but my mom my mom or and her mom
collected ceramic shoes they were
little tiny shoes and you they she she
still has them
they're on like this like you're saying
this huge [ __ ] display case
like it's you know like it's the holy
grail little ceramic
shoes that's [ __ ] trap that's trash
man that's like
genetic trash mentality do you think
that's going to be worth it it's going
to pay off
well those star wars figures might pay
off i wouldn't mind taking a look at
them i'm not going to lie
give your mom a fair price for you she
doesn't know [ __ ] about that stuff so i
just let her fly
even better there we go yeah there you
go so can take good advantage of her
so no metal detector all right no metal
detector no and i
always but here's here's another funny
thing as a blind guy i always kind of
wish i did
have a medal oh dude i gotta tell you i
had one i bought it at radio shack for
like 112 bucks
and i thought i was going to find
[ __ ] it it barely [ __ ] worked i
would
remember i would hold it up like next to
the car and [ __ ] it wouldn't even go off
next to the car
it ran off [ __ ] like double a
batteries i was like this ain't gonna
find
anything my [ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ]
dad would send me out on the beach i'd
just be like
look like the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ]
fat kid walking down the beach
oh that's funny um oh i got one kip yeah
i got one does anyone in your family
extended family own a camper or an
rv uh my uncle mike used to like way
back
with my family still talk to each other
of course never i never got to
ollie's uncle mike it's always
interesting as a baby
my uncle michael is the trashiest but my
favorite uncle he was
like they are all my finger uncle he was
the
he used to burp and say like good out
like yeah you can't
you can't be a good uncle and not be a
trashy uncle i'm the trashy uncle right
now
sure i'm the true uncle for sure yeah i
do the diarrhea song the whole nine
yards it [ __ ] kills
i haven't had the uh fortunate ability
to interact with my nephew
as often as i'd like yet i've only met
him once because they
he's uh one years old and he's across
the country so
i uh but i can't wait to be the trashy
uncle
yeah well i think the fact that you've
only met him once you've has solidified
you as
the trashy uncle oh for sure so far yeah
you guys already have beef with each
other principle
yeah all right what do you got big man
pretty good what do i got i got
uh what was your pet situation growing
up
up there in buffalo i um we had a dog
uh named tucker and i picked him out at
the spca we don't
we don't know what uh breed he was
we took him to a couple vets all of them
said different breeds
and uh he's italian yeah
i mean he was the most it was a dog with
the most personality that i've ever seen
in my life
like he would just do [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
and
he was the best it was like it was like
a kid with his dog and then i had to
like hold him when he died
it was like the worst [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then i was like
i was like i'm never having another
[ __ ] dog ever again and then my mom
got like
two dogs right away and i was like
[ __ ] these dogs you know what i mean i
don't know it was like uh yeah i don't
want to get close to him yeah
yeah it was weird so yeah i was like i
love that dog and i don't understand how
people can just replace dogs so quickly
it's tough ma'am yeah josh has got some
scars gang he's got some skulls yeah
sorry about that i also had a turtle at
one point
turtles are trash was it yeah but it was
a small one
oh yeah and i think my dad just ended up
flushing it down the toilet because he
was like this is [ __ ] stupid
[Laughter]
and uh did it smell they smell really
bad oh they smell like [ __ ] and that's
why my dad i think my dad was like
just like what am i doing these things
are they live to be a hundred
it was also like trash was like hamster
i don't even know why my parents keep
the tires on any of these pets but like
we had a hamster we had a [ __ ] uh
bird
one time oh dude these are all i have my
first question is have you ever owned a
pet bird it's right there these are
no-no's josh and it was like a
it was like a parakeet or whatever and
it still was like [ __ ]
my parents just bailed on it quickly
they were like what were we thinking
the dog was like the only one that
lasted the the biggest trash one of all
of
in that world is by far the guinea pig
or the ferret i think a hamster is
grosser than a guinea pig
you think why so because a hamster i
think is more
rat like yeah hamsters i don't trust
hamsters and i remember like having it
and going like
this is gross i remember like looking at
it and going like
why do we own a rat
that's kind of yeah we're like taking it
out of its
box and [ __ ] and like it would escape it
would like run around it would just live
in our house we're like we have this
rodent running around our home i know
like dude
we had gerbils we had gerbils and we
would put them on our head and they
would sit there his name was peanuts
[ __ ] yeah and he was like [ __ ] on our
heads yeah
can you believe that [ __ ] i can't not
believe we let rodents
oh dude it's crazy it's cause you're
trying yeah it's because we're [ __ ]
garbage of course yeah right
did you ever keep any of the tanks or
the cages after the pets had gone
did you ever have an empty bird cage
just hanging in your house
oh my mom has definitely used an empty
tank like a fish tank for decor
decoration
it's like putting other things in it
that's
real like i saw that in southern living
i'm not sure bon appetit
that's trash probably a place to put the
surplus
precious moments because she was
that's always a dead giveaway qvc is
tough
wow um i remember my mom got on the
phone
with qvc buying a uh a hoodie
or not a hoodie but what's the a crew
neck sweatshirt like the sweatshirt
without the hood yeah just like up to
commemorate
uh the iraq war
what was it the uh operation that when
we stormed in there what was yeah
yeah back in this house you're talking
in the 90s yeah she got
she got on qvc on the phone like going
like oh i'm on it like that kind of [ __ ]
she was on the live home yeah josh come
on josh get over here i'm on
i'm on the i cannot believe she was like
i'm out on the phone they're like you
get the you're gonna are you excited to
purchase this uh
desert storm sweatshirt right here to
come commemorate our victory over
the middle east and she's like i can't
wait to get it you know like that kind
of thing so
oh hold on she must have been telling
the girls about that for a couple of
yeah everyone ran in the room
that's a game changer when you're a dude
small town buffalo you're making it on
qvc
that's a national program yeah that's a
[ __ ] tv
credit dude name is streaming after you
jesus christ
ever been a member of a studio audience
any member of your family
uh in nickelodeon we were in
uh double dares wow
very nice in nickelodeon studios down
there orlando
yes very and uh they actually asked me
they go
uh i don't know why he asked me this but
he asked me how old i was
mark summers he goes yeah i said i would
you talk to [ __ ] mark summers
yeah like in the pre like the warm-up
thing not mark summers the guy who did
the warm-up gotcha gotcha wait harvey
i don't remember who it was what you did
the warm-up what were you a [ __ ]
stage hand there i i
i knew the guy harvey that was the
announcer and warm-up guy for double
dare
i didn't i don't it might have been a
guy named harvey but someone he came up
to me and goes how old are you and i
said i think i was four or six or
something i don't know
josh i don't think that guy worked there
[Laughter]
whatever i said i don't know and uh
he goes uh how long you been
six and i go about three years and it
got a huge laugh
and i'll never forget that that's a good
fit that is
i'll never forget that that i got a huge
laugh and i didn't know why i got it but
i just remember going like
hey i'm good at this yeah yeah let's get
this kid on camera
yeah yeah yeah oh dude then i was like
bitten by the bug right there
oh that's [ __ ] great dude i did i did
sea world
and i remember the guy came up to me at
sea world and he goes hey hey kid can
you jump through a fire
hey guys hey kid you like mackerel how
long can you hold your breath
excuse me son by any chance are you
scared of killer whales
and also underwater
[Laughter]
can we squeeze you into a mermaid
costume he was like can you
[ __ ] you want to come up and like do
the free willy
i was like dude that was [ __ ] a
decade before blackfish i was like dude
i ain't i sell i smell a setup when i
see one dude get out of here
no [ __ ] way am i being the fall guy
for this that would be the
darkest pedophile ring scandal as if
there was just like guys
grooving people to be like hey do you
want to get kissed by shamu
if you want shamu to kiss you you got to
kiss somewhere else
get some [ __ ] action going under the
bleachers let's go we had a place
up in uh ontario like because buffalo's
so close to canada
yeah and basically called marine land
that was like a trashier version of
something oh yeah i bet you the budget
was not high
they were like living in probably hotel
rooms those [ __ ] dolphins
there was there was also a place like
down down the highway called
african lion safari where you could
drive your car
and there would be lions but they'd be
so drunk
they'd just be like chilling like this
and you could drive a car by them and
[ __ ]
watch them throw like some meat at them
and stuff dude the 90s was [ __ ] wide
open so far you could do whatever you
dude that shit's still open i know oh
yeah african safari in the middle of
[ __ ] buffalo if that isn't
it's up in ontario canada niagara falls
on ken
that's somehow less african i feel yeah
and niagara fall niagara falls is pretty
trashy right
oh my god dude yeah our side of niagara
falls
the the canadian side is trashy and
that's the nice side that's the yeah
that's
our side looks like johannesburg and
then
every now and then you see a halal cart
around there you know what i mean that's
about it
yeah nothing wrong with a good halal
cart shout out to the halal guys on 50
seconds
had it last week there are like
shaq it's like shacks and like
oh it is terrible yeah niagara falls we
did it i did it as a kid
and i remember we were looking over the
canadian side and
i was like oh let's go over there
because it's like it's bigger buildings
it's like a city yeah
it's like it's attractive by sight
especially as a little kid i'm like
that's where shit's happening yeah i'm
like yeah it's popping over there and
i'm like can we go over there my dad
goes
maybe next time kid maybe your poor dad
your poor dad and i always picture that
poor dad that breaks
because there's like dads who bring
their families over from japan
and i always think like that you know
they're probably like i can picture
myself being a japanese dad and going
the american side's way better than the
canadians of course that's what you
would think
so then you go you schedule your whole
vacation and then your kids like this
blows and you're like
i [ __ ] worked in my japanese job
for a hundred years to pay for this
[ __ ] ticket
the japanese got it rough out here
that's a tough look when you see
like if uh like for a dad to like feel
like he let down his kids on the
vacation
like that's pretty good huh not bad kids
are like [ __ ] you this sucks
ah man yeah you're like huh see what i
did and then like it would have been
cooler if you do this and you're like
shut up yeah i know you ungrateful fat
piece of [ __ ] get out of here
i we did that to my parents a couple of
times and i still i still feel bad about
just [ __ ] ruining vacations left and
right for no reason oh yeah dude
we also there's a [ __ ] there's a big
the big to do
and i don't know it was when i was there
the big we got our hands on a couple of
tickets
was the [ __ ] wax museum
yeah in niagara falls and i remember
walking around with my dad being like
what the [ __ ] is this we drove [ __ ]
seven and a half hours
to [ __ ] look at a wax brad pitt hey
that's not [ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger
what kind of [ __ ] you trying to pull
oh there's wax museums and haunted
houses and yeah
real the real thing for people for well
teenagers and buffalo is when you turn
19 you can go up there and drink
in canada yeah yeah yeah
and it's right over the moose head right
over the [ __ ] bridge it's ten minute
drive
so yeah if you go to a haunted house on
vacation
all right i don't care if you're from
japan
or what you're [ __ ] trash yeah how
about this
uh well there was not only a hard rock
cafe up there but
i think one of the final planet
hollywood's wow there
oh man that's where you stole the
silverware
yeah planet hollywood's where you start
i never understood that
that or the hard work the hard part
hollywood memorabilia [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
trashy
i remember we went to the smithsonian
and like in dc we went to a certain part
and it was like fonzie's jacket i'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me with this
shirt from seinfeld archie bunkers that
was the only part of the smithsonian i
gave a [ __ ] about that
i was like there's argy bunker's chair
yeah there's a shirt from seinfeld i was
like cool this stuff's way cool my dad's
like hey the
first pocket that was these faces over
there
yeah sputnik's too hot no i want to
check out the puffy shirt dad
yeah i did oh god holy [ __ ]
jacket kippy what else she got for him
uh
i think let's just uh we gotta wrap up
in a minute but let's just do some of
the basics
sure some of the go-to's that we always
do these are recurring ones
that the the fan the listeners are very
adamant about so we kind of go over with
all
with all the guests um you want to leave
you can take it yeah uh first one off
the bat i'm guessing a yes did you leave
butter on the counter or did you put it
in the fridge
growing up in buffalo um my mom was one
of the we had the tubs
we did no real large nice wait a minute
i'm sorry i don't even know if it's
margarine but just
the tubs of like i cannot believe it's
butter
wow that's all right blue bonnet you
know
i still do those did you leave that
really did you leave it in the fridge
yeah and would you use the container for
something else once the once the i can't
believe it's not butter was gone
my grandma 100 percent did that [ __ ]
sure
my grandma was big depression narrow
stuff so she would like save rubber
bands and be like oh never know
you know yeah here we go
yeah she would save the tops of like
these things on the tops of your tabs
what yeah and then she would like i
don't know
what things she would submit them to but
she
or something for like you yeah i don't
know what it was there was a program
where you could
collect those and i don't know if it was
like charity or you got like
they went to you know the schools or
something yes it went to schools
yes she'd have like grocery bags of
these [ __ ] what are the kids gonna do
with the tops of [ __ ] red bull guys
like
how much money could the schools be
getting out of this that you are
dedicating a great portion of your life
to collecting them
do a bake sale something make a couple
of bucks yeah you know how to make a
[ __ ] lemon square
what the [ __ ] the juice is not worth the
squeeze on this one i don't think for
the schools
not even close it's so funny that you
say that that's like a recurring in 100
years we'll get a new basketball what
the [ __ ]
i mean have you seen the [ __ ] state
of the schools you're not helping
i mean that's [ __ ] funny
um all right and i guess last one would
be
milk for dinner when you were growing up
did you drink milk for dinner
i have a big aversion to milk my mom
tried to peddle it on me but i do not
i'm
i'm super grossed out by milk to be
honest really
i don't like the smell of it the sight
of it if it spills on a counter i'm like
let's light the counter on fire wow
shout out to vitamin d oh man yeah he's
the drink you could name any liquid
and i would prefer to consume it over
milk
i'm talking about any liquid that's all
right in my book
where would you growing up where would
you keep the ketchup where would you
keep the uh the syrup
keep the ketchup in the fridge or keep
it in the cabinet
uh i think it would stay in like the
cabinet until it was opened
of course then it would go in the fridge
proper proper procedure
classy yeah and the maple syrup
and the maple syrup again another
product that i'm grossed out by
weirdly what's not like maple syrup what
do you put on your eggos or your french
toast
i'm a i'm a big egg i do not eat like
french toast or
waffles i'm just eating eggs straight up
eggs guy hot sauce guy
not a syrup guy i don't like sweets very
much
the smell of maple syrup actually made
me faint one time in school like that
old
remember that old smell and stuff like
maple syrup
made me fake i was like wow so grossed
out
jesus that's wild that is
yeah i was not expecting that the milk
i'll give you
yeah but no french toast so you don't
like pancakes
no no not really jesus this guy's
something else
bet you i bet your dad makes a good
flapjack on the griddle oh he does he's
great i mean eggs
flapjacks well he probably knows his way
around the [ __ ]
somebody that can work the flat top oh i
[ __ ] love
browns i mean he can make breakfast like
crazy i love it
i'm chubbing up over here yeah all right
um i think that's it right i'm guessed
and
i gotta be honest with you [ __ ]
garbage through and through and i love
it hell yeah
hell yeah i own that i think that's part
of my brand to be quite honest with you
yeah
i knew that i would get along great on
this one the question when there was a
question mark i'm like you can just put
a period
[Laughter]
i would you are garbage yeah doesn't
have to come out
yeah definitely garbage i wouldn't say
uh
sophisticated garbage i would actually
say
calculated yes calculated you're
regulated
in your trash which i respect i respect
that yeah
[ __ ] absolutely amazing josh anything
you want the folks out there to know
before we get you out of here
uh i'm just uh all my shows are like
pending or whatever but
you can follow me on twitter at j
underscore potter and they're listed up
there the ones that have been
rescheduled and they're
going off as far as i know for now and
other than that i'm uh
i can be seen on your mom's house uh and
uh
also i'm just playing video games on
twitch so you can subscribe to my
twitch channel which is twitch.tv slash
josh underscore potter that's
about it congratulations to you guys by
the way on uh gas digital now and
everything
thank you thank you so much brother uh
ladies and gentlemen mr josh potter
uh [ __ ] fantastic episode kippy what
do you got
uh guys at kevin ryan comedy on all
social media just uh as always you know
itunes make sure you rate review
subscribe keep us in the top 200. we
appreciate all the support thus far
also uh you can sign up for gas digital
uh you can use code ayg you'll save
uh you'll get a discount every month
plus we get to wet our beaks a little
bit and that's
the most important [ __ ] part uh also
you'll get uh you know
hd live stream of both episodes each
week uh you'll get in the live chat you
get
you get all the content before everybody
we're gonna start doing stuff uh just
for the subscribers and stuff like that
so get
in buy low sell high you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's right baby we love you guys very
much um
like kippy said just please uh keep the
reviews up keep sharing it keep telling
a friend
at h foley on ice on twitter and
foldygrams on
instagram a big shout out to our
producer dylan
thank you buddy you're the absolute best
mr josh potter thank you so much brother
and we'll see you guys
appreciate it buddy thank you gang